well alright then okay okay over as I
murder people
oh goody goody gumdrops I'm sure I'm not
gonna die all right
two balls exactly what I needed in this
boy Oh things are going so well for me
all right then
well my leg seems to be broken with us
okay i unlock the win I just gotta get
in the wind don't stick your head in my
ass oh well that takes care of one
problem
my son betrays me Oh dad goddamn it why
go to that almost hurt me oh okay
if I could just for one goddamn second
get some goddamn peace
there we go we're pretty clear he's
gonna blow up I'm gonna I'm gonna get
this Hobbit against this Abba to get
this [ __ ] you wait
Oh Margaret blue impossible so that's
how it's gonna be
yeah more choices no choice of fans
that's gonna be falling oh [ __ ] oh all
right saddle doesn't have a lovely wife
Sal has an overbearing nagging wife mrs.
Claus if you didn't know get down here
okay to a saddle levels
Santa's voice can't hold on I don't know
what Santa's gosh
ba-gawk-oh
anymore okay well she's gonna vacua 12th
and still has his balls intact
oh well shocked
markiplier can't win okay jump I'm gonna
jump on my face I'm gonna jump it about
a wreck it ah I'm gonna wreck it I'm
gonna wreck it I'm gonna wreck it okay
Rex bus by Marga bar rope swing I
haven't even seen a rope swing in a long
time probably cuz I hate them huh but
apparently I'm good at this one because
oh because
ow because out because ow god damn it
markiplier secret mission hello mark
your mission is to take the secret files
in that building over there just smash
through the window and jump over watch
out that windows really expensive boom
like a boat okay where the CIA oh I
don't have time to listen to your
ramblings
I've got a secret mission to do and
secret files to see miss me you only hit
my balls
that's hardly any of me thank you okay
goodbye
oh this feels bad he killed himself
but ow god damn it damn it damn it
ah Oh indeed oh oh so much ow
okay oh my god did I win oh okay I think
I'm okay now I think my balls have been
severed but still not going too well
century ahead okay thank you got it
I'm good spike fall well let's go son no
time to waste
only death to get to me hey well then
i'll my butt's but okay i don't feel
like i one another
okay mark me i
oh no oh oh there's a meteor on the way
oh oh
kick kick kick
maaaybe all through here we go
I got one ball don't die [ __ ] I'm gonna
win this ball throw [ __ ] no it's a
punishment worse than death escaping the
box you'll never keep me any of your
screws thank you burglar parkour I'm
gonna do a sick leaked
triple flip jump axial presser okay I'm
gonna do a sickly axel [ __ ] oh oh
portal the game art the game communist
in the game hold control
okay so there's also any whoa hey did
you really jump without oh oh that was
Easter Egg okay I didn't know that I
needed to jump to select one how about
portal the game let's try that I don't
think I wet I okay bad what I okay I
will go in this portal Oh
oh that's so cool I'm alright let's try
art the game how about that this is so
cool this is so cool I'll be so cool hey
look it's starry night and that's a
screamer by not Van Gogh bull dick okay
how about communism the game where does
this ow
okay level 1 level 2 get out of my way I
said
that was amazing thank you Gatsby
markiplier doesn't want to die this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye